what they saw into unit there's plenty
Christians and locusts okay but I didn't
find a single one with a restriction on
the domain like the claim we're gonna
talk about today okay it does appear in
three in it sometimes because of these
restrictions they often have to do with
the parameter right so parametric's and
so it's a three you know topic only
right so they sometimes appear but when
they do appear it always says find the
locus can find the equation of the
longest and state any restrictions on
the domain okay so they give you this
big red flashing clue to say look
there's gonna be some of these and
you'll need to find them okay if you're
under the for unit that's exams that's
where you get these and they just expect
those guys to work it out okay so even
though these might be a bit tricky and
the methods I'll show you there too can
be quite confusing if you need to use
them they'll tell you okay so let's
start by just redefining what the lock
is okay can anyone give me like a one
sentence or like a one phrase definition
or la kiss is what good good
to set of points and it's not just it's
not just any set of points right what's
the the quality that unifies all these
points together good good so whichever
one you say either satisfies or behaves
a quotient or whatever there's so
geometric rule or geometric property
that all of the points exhibit right
okay now usually we would say well
that's actually doing example okay show
yourself up a little while said backsies
okay and we'll pick a super simple
example one of the first ones that we
did if I gave you two points okay let's
say a okay and let's put B
like one okay now if I said what's the
locus of all the points that now I'm
going to give you the property which are
equidistant from an babe
okay non equation how would you define
that how did you describe it in words
what is the locus of those points
equidistant from a line which line is a
specific good good so if we if we
drawing this interval okay the longest
that I'm interested in is the
perpendicular it's not quite a bisector
but I'm just gonna call it that's it
though perpendicular bisector of that
interval a B okay well because it's a
bit of a mouthful and it's not always
such a convenience for the way we
usually give an equation right so the
questions you get are what's the
equation of the bacchus equation in this
case is okay
now the important thing to get is when
you're doing against drew myself when
you're two eating are all markets right
you'll get this equation but this
equation right and what do we say the
perpendicular bisector this thing is the
lockers
okay this red thing and this is the
equation of the locus but they're not
the same thing okay they might signify
the same thing but they're not always
exactly the same now in this case they
are right but where they're not that's
what this is about okay so let me try
and Segway into it and explain why we
need restrictions but I draw your
attention back to one of the earlier
derivatives that you learned I gave you
this function okay you would say that
dy/dx is equal to
okay now again for the sake of argument
right let's just quickly join this thing
log X what is that look like that guy
okay that's got NASA into this axis yeah
what does this look like everyone does
the motion with their arms good so
you're getting sorry I did it backwards
yeah yeah in this kind of shape right
now
straightaway you can see it is a problem
right if this is our function and I want
its derivative okay
the equation of the derivative and the
derivative just like the equation of the
walkers in the Marcus they're not the
same thing
what's the difference what's the
difference in the derivative edits
equation yeah that's right it gives you
a stuff over here a derivative where the
graph itself doesn't even exist okay so
you can see the equation is not the same
as the derivative because there's a part
which doesn't matter right in other
words there's a restriction on okay what
is the restriction in this exit greater
than zero right that's that's totally
what your design right okay so that's
why when we're doing Waqas okay you're
gonna end up you can do all your work
and you're going to come up with some
equation okay
sometimes it's fine but other times like
here right you're gonna have to say well
sometimes it is this equation and other
times that doesn't make any sense okay
so